there's sean payton making good on his
promise to get slimed if the saints win
in the nickelodeon game
and there it is
sean payton got slimed the the [ __ ] i
wouldn't be
i wouldn't yeah i've always got anything
but he's got he's got a he's got a shoe
deal he'll get he'll he'll there's
plenty more where those came from he'll
probably
like auction the jordans that got slimed
for charity and make a bunch of money
for somebody which uh good one
but
but but uh
the nickelodeon broadcast i wouldn't be
on nickelodeon nickelodeon was more from
my perspective the thing that was on and
it was loud and you said and you said oh
like your phone ringing during segment
on tv you mean like like that like you
just forgot to turn like that kind of
loud and annoying sorry i i i i
explained to you i explained to you
what's going on here before the show and
uh you know um i forgot about it that's
an issue right now okay so uh so anyway
talk a little bit about the saints game
while i figure out what's going on all
right you figured that out there yes i
mean the saints the story of the day you
know what i know and anybody watching
that football game the saints defense i
mean holy cow
that was domination really other than
one drive and a drop trick you know
trick pass by whims where hey that would
have been a big play who knows what
happens with the football game the story
of the day is the new orleans saints
defense absolutely suffocated the
chicago bears to where there was really
just never a point in the football game
where you thought chicago can drive the
ball
a few drives in this game to score a
touchdown or make it competitive that
way you just quit going well i hope
their defense can hang in there i hope
their defense can hang in there that's
the only way the bears will have a
chance but new orleans defense against
that bears offense which yes is better
than it was earlier this year but still
that formula of you know average run
game and bootlegs and that's really all
you got to offer against the saints
defense that's got some big bad dudes up
front
good linebackers awesome secondary and
then a guy in dennis allen who does
stuff where you just go i don't know
what the hell defense this is but
everybody's covered i don't know what
the hell alignment this is but damn
they're creating chaos and it was just
total butt whooping on that side of the
ball by the saints defense
i saw an awesome tweet last night and i
can't remember who posted it but the
message was this if they want kids to
get interested in football why did they
make kids watch the bears
that's a good point
the bears
were who we thought they were and they
did exactly what we thought they would
do now it was interesting in the first
half until the drop on the great trick
play well designed well executed until
javon wins just let it go right through
his hands and
that would have been a moment that could
have changed everything made it seven to
seven giving the bears a lift and the
flip side is when that doesn't work when
you shoot your shot there when it's the
plan that you surely had in the works
for days and everyone's excited here's
the play we're going to use it it's
going to work and it's going to be great
and when everything works but the
easiest part of it that's got to take
the air out of the team chris well
definitely and it's a game where they're
listen these are human beings they're
smart they realize that they needed a
play or two like that to win the game
and maybe another lucky bounce their way
so that's where it's deflating because
you just go ah i mean we're not going to
have a lot of opportunities you know all
together to make it happen but man
that's saint stephen's mic put it in
this way that last drive of the game by
the bears was a 99-yard drive they had
239 yards total offense on the day so
that's what kind of 130 yards before
that drive that's domination by the
saints d
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports